all right welcome everybody let's get
started after a long um holiday weekend
in the united states federal holiday we
were off with the latest covet news it's
it's really pretty good uh in five
states the covet situation is getting
worse
in 45 plus dc
it's getting significantly better to the
point where cases in the united states
have now plummeted by about 50 percent
since their delta peak so
all good news uh vaccine doses are up a
little bit
um cases are down deaths are now down
and the question is becoming
what happens in the winter season so
let's start at the very beginning how
are cases looking globally
globally cases are down from their delta
peak of about six hundred and sixty
thousand a day an insane number
down to about four hundred thousand a
day four hundred and four thousand a day
that's a decline of nearly thirty nine
percent
now in the united states cases are down
even more precipitously if you believe
the data which i think we've talked
about this before
big picture we mostly can even if we're
not getting
the full story from every single state
uh cases in the u.s down from their
delta peak of about a hundred and sixty
seven thousand
to about eighty five thousand cases a
day still a ton of cases
but it's a decline of it's about fifty
percent forty nine point something
percent now the caveat here
is
do those numbers include what is
obviously slower reporting thanks to the
long holiday weekend these numbers might
end up being adjusted up a little bit as
the testing and reporting kind of
catches up and is integrated into these
numbers but big picture a significant
decline at this point
in terms of deaths which often follow
cases by three to four weeks globally
deaths are down about 34 from their
delta peak which remember it's not the
full pandemic peak okay
the delta global death peak was about 10
000 deaths a day at one point we were at
14 000 in a previous peak so down from
about 10 000 a day to like 67.50 within
the united states the death decline is
not
quite as sharp
uh deaths in the u.s down about 26 from
their delta peak now
around 1400 per day remember this
relevant data point
when we want to think about just how are
we doing
in general
in a normal flu season in the u.s
there's about a hundred deaths a day
again they're not really a hundred a day
they're concentrated during flu season
you've got more than 100 a day during
flu season fewer than 100 a day in the
summer but about 100 a day
covid of course is still way way higher
than that multiples higher in terms of
vaccination we are seeing daily vaccine
doses trickle up a little bit remember
that daily vaccinations at one point had
surpassed 3 million new doses per day in
the u.s that was in mid april
that has come all the way down at one
point down to 500 000 new doses a day
pathetic number completely pathetic and
then as the delta variant started to
surge so did vaccination as joe biden
announced some vaccine requirements
there was another surge in vaccination
and recently we've seen daily doses
administered in the u.s
up to about a million a day we could be
doing so much better we have so many
doses available
but you still prefer to see
one million per day
rather than 500 000.
globally new doses are also up you might
remember last week i said hey guys we're
seeing 23 million doses a day
we're up to 25 million doses a day
globally these are still really small
numbers
but i'll mention them last week we were
seeing
0.29
of the population getting a dose
that's up to now
0.32 of the global population is getting
a dose each day these are tiny tiny
numbers but it's an increase and we'll
take any increase that we can get now
compared to the vaccination rate of any
other planet in our solar system we're
doing really well we're really kicking
some ass if we compare earth to other
planets um where do we go from here
not really clear
we've not yet won i saw a funny article
which said fauci says we shouldn't
declare victory prematurely i was
thinking
we shouldn't declare victory prematurely
again because we already did i mean some
places never conceded there was even a
battle but there were some premature
declarations of victory as well beyond
beyond that we've got to see what
happens in terms of the winter there is
the view that coinciding with flu season
we're going to see another coke another
coveted peak
if we're going to see that we would
expect to see the numbers turn around
relatively quickly as we're starting to
get into the cold season in much of the
much of the country
in terms of those who say we're not
going to see it they are saying no no
because of vaccination and because of
everything that's going on
this is now completely sort of like
unlinked from the seasonality of flu
season we're not going to see a winter
spike remains to be seen in about six
weeks we're going to know but in the
interim let's hope things continue going
in the right direction
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping